>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
I'M BRET BAIER IN WASHINGTON.
WE HAVE TWO FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE.
BILL HEMMER TRAVELING WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN EL SALVADOR.
HAS WILLIAM BARR'S FIRST
INTERVIEW IN THAT ROLE, BARR HAS
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION AND IS
NOW BOWING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF IT.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN THE
MOMENT.
FIRST, OR OTHER EXCLUSIVE.
AND THEN THE
AN INTERVIEW WITH THE BROTHER
OF MICHAEL FLYNN BACK IN THE
NEWS AFTER A FEDERAL JUDGE
ORDERED PARTS OF THE MUELLER
REPORT TO BE UNREDACTED AND MADE
PUBLIC IN THE CRIMINAL CASE
AGAINST MICHAEL FLYNN.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME THE FEDERAL
JUDGE HAS ORDERED THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO MAKE PUBLIC
PORTIONS OF THE REPORT THE
AGENCY HAD KEPT SECRET.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING THIS CASE FROM THE
BEGINNING AND HAS THIS INTERVIE
INTERVIEW.
>> CONFIRMATION OF THE FBI IN
VACATION OF MY FLYNN
, EVIDENCE OF A LONG-RUNNING
EFFORT TO TRAP HIS BROTHER, THE
FEDERAL JUDGE ORDERS THE RELEASE
OF MORE SECRET DOCUMENTS.
NEW SPECIAL COUNSEL RECORD SHOW
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
MIKE FLYNN REPORTED MULTIPLE
INSTANCES BEFORE AND AFTER HIS
GUILTY PLEA WHERE HE OR HIS
LAWYERS GOT CALLS FROM
INDIVIDUALS CONNECTED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION OR CONGRESS,
"THAT COULD HAVE AFFECTED BOTH
HIS WILLINGNESS TO COOPERATE IN
THE COMPLETENESS OF THE
COOPERATION."
THE DEFENDANT EVEN PROVIDED A
VOICE MAIL RECORDING OF ONE SUCH
MUNICATION.
SOURCES CLOSE TO THE BETTER TELL
FOX THAT FLYNN HAD A JOINT
AGREEMENT WITH THE PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM AND AFTER HE BEGAN
COOPERATING WITH A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYERS
SOUGHT TO PROTECT PRIVILEGED
MATERIAL.
SPEAKING EXCLUSIVELY TO FOX,
FLYNN'S BROTHER IS REACTING TO
THE MUELLER REPORT AND THE KEY
SECTION INDICATING THE RETIRED
GENERAL WAS ALREADY UNDER FBI
INVESTIGATION DURING THE 2016
PRESIDENTIAL TRANSITION.
>> GENERAL FLYNN WENT THROUGH 19
SESSIONS WITH 90 HOURS OF
TORTUROUS INTERVIEWS AND THIS
NEVER CAME UP THE ENTIRE TIME.
>> BURIED IN VOLUME TWO, THE
REPORTS STATE THAT THE
INVESTIGATORS COME ACROSS THE
FBI PROBE WHILE EXAMINING
FLYNN'S DISCUSSIONS WITH
AMBASSADOR KISLYAK.
BASED ON HIS RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT, FLYNN'S
CONTACT WITH KIDS WE
BECAME A KEY INVESTIGATION.
THAT TIMING MATTERS BECAUSE IT
WAS PREVIOUSLY THOUGHT THAT
FLYNN'S PHONE CALLS WITH KISLYAK
PROMPTED THE FBI CASE.
A 27 YEAR BUSES       JUSTICE DP
A 27 YEAR BUSES       JUSTICE DR
A 27 YEAR BUSES       JUSTICE DM
A 27 YEAR BUSES       JUSTICE DN
A 27 YEAR BUSES       JUSTICE DT
VETERAN REVIEWED THE PASSAGE.
>> IT APPEARS TO ME THAT THE USE
OF THE WORD PREVIOUSLY IS
--
>> KNOWN AS A 302 WITH FORMER
ATTACKING ASSISTANT GENERAL MARY
McCORD WHO HELPED STIR THE
RUSSIA PRO AND FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED, IT SEEMS
THAT GENERAL FLYNN WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION LONG BEFORE IT WAS
COMMON KNOWLEDGE BUT WHY WAS I
NOT TOLD SO I CAN MAKE A CHANGE?
THE PASSAGE BACKS OF THE
FAMILIES LONG-HELD CONCERN.
>> BECAUSE OF HIS VOCAL
CRITICISM OF THE OBAMA
ILLUSTRATION IN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY WHICH HE CAME OUT OF,
MY SUSPICION IS THEY WERE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY COULD TO TRIP
THEM UP AND TRAP HIM.
>> THE REFERENCE TO THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT CONTACTS MAY BE THE
2015 MOSCOW DINNERWARE FLYNN SAT
NEXT TO THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT,
JOE
>> HE BRIEF THE DIA PRIOR TO
THAT.
>> OF THE RUSSIA REPORT FOUND
THERE WAS NO FBI BRIEFING
WARNING THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN THAT
THEY WERE RUNNING A